[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui ce beau jeune homme
nous on te demande pas qui je suis un
fils et mon train de vie ici bas n'est
pas assurée et fleuves dérouleront à la
mer tout est si beau les roses tous dans
la merde
lueur d'espoir mais permet je suis mal
luné
ce quart de pierre finira par tout
ruiner
amaury car souvent ne font pas la peine
mais il met sur la place de la paix
j'ai relu les coeurs tienne nous et dans
le quart temps que je te rappelle me
cacher
mais pas plus
[Musique]
quand j'ai un sale coup
c'était mapaq
et démago
m a pas qu'eux
mais dur ça vous tu m'aimes ce ton
problème
même pas le mien tu casses sur les
changes ta famille fait pas le poids
j'ai signé pour le nict âgées en plus le
groupe
je ne sais pas le ton les gros de votre
balcon on s'est croisé à ans les oueds
quoi qu'ils soient réseau dégâts les
personnes de l'argent j'ai vu les mais
envers en palestine on se croit tout
prix swiss ball tir sa période
je suis rendu là quartier c'est dans la
quartier tant que je n'aurai plus jamais
je vais pas le cacher
[Musique]
là
c'était une pac l'orangé ans à bout
[Musique]
à
c'était ma bague
[Musique]
map
oh
mais j'aime ça vous
nitish palandri désolé je fais le vide
et rôle et que les prix pour m'épauler
plus aucune envie désormais qui part en
vrille
je fais deux
je n'ai que des prix bas
plus aucune envie
arrivé dans sa roue
[Musique]
car j'ai un sale
thema pas que
[Musique]
mais j'aime ça
non
[Applaudissements]